conclusion does that lead me to I think
the women are dumber than the men
because I think her emotions just get in
the way we're too emotional we see a
problem we get emotional about it where
the men can just think what up guys
welcome to the just hurry things YouTube
channel and welcome to my whiteboard
videos before I start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way in let's get
started so today's lesson is why women
are dumb
now please please guys hear me out just
wait don't get mad ladies I know I know
you're like keyboard Warriors are ready
but women out of the two genders are
definitely the Dumber gender now I
believe that they're trying to make us
think we're more important and more
special than we are therefore so we
think we're better than the average man
and they have all these fake jobs and
institutions to make us feel better
about ourselves okay so I got to
thinking if women are so smart right and
women can do everything a man can do
where is the female Elon Musk where is
the female Bill Gates why haven't we
produced this you would think if we were
so smart this would have come up and it
seems like every woman they've propped
up in history as um as a top earning
woman it seems to come out later that
there was some man behind her so I got
to thinking are women better at any is
there anything women can be great at
without the guidance of a man and I just
think that our emotions are too
distracting we think with our emotions
first men think with logic first even
the most successful the smartest woman I
know still think emotions first and my
theory is they created so let's let's do
the average life of a woman so we have a
woman right look at this I'm gonna give
her some nice nice pretty and we have a
man here so this is gonna be Susie and
this is gonna be Bob so what if Susie
and Bob do they go to all right sorry
guys I can't draw but they go to school
now the school system is woman
teachers
women administrators and in my opinion A
system that is nicer to women than to
men now what is the average life of an
average woman and an average man first
off they go to school and in my opinion
the schools favor the women and how do I
think they do this one it is a
completely female staff now let's look
at the last hundred years are women
typically sympathetic to to men no no
um and our women typically pretty
emotional yes and that is what is
teaching the men and the women now there
are studies that have come out during
coven that indicated that when women
were home and their cameras were off
that they actually got worse grades
indicating that maybe the teachers favor
young women and it would kind of make
sense with what we see in society the
world is generally nicer to women than
it typically is to men
so women will get A's and the men will
get C's and remember guys in the 70s and
80s they actually switched a lot of the
schooling to make it more feminine and
subjective they started weighing heavier
papers essays and projects rather than
standardized testing schools moved away
from this and as schools moved away from
this we saw IQs drop and we saw men
doing worse so the men go through the
life and they get the C's and throughout
this they have a bunch of feminist
liberal ass women that didn't have kids
of their own so they just want to ruin
yours and then the women go to college
and the men go to Dropout okay so Women
College the men will drop out except for
like the hard things which women don't
want to do either like we look at
College the women get all the nice fuzzy
subjects the men do the hard stuff
typically so the women go to school and
they automatically think they're smarter
than the men because you know the
teachers are telling the men to sit down
they're giving them worse grades even
though they do the same work and if
they're not woke which men aren't really
with the woke stuff
um you'll just see the teachers making
the men's life a living hell so the men
say F this and drop out and the women go
to college now some of the men do go to
college too so now let's talk about the
job right now we're seeing men actively
being discriminated against for high
paying jobs I spoke to a recruiter this
weekend in the tech industry and he said
that he actively discriminates a met
against men and hires women so then the
women under 30 start to make a lot of
money
um and they typically make money
um three ways they'll either monetize
their beauty or go into an industry
that's subsidized by the government uh
so health care for example and I think
that the government gives us all these
useless jobs to make us think we're more
efficient than we actually are or the
men actually do the hard jobs or say F
this and leave they'll look at the
market and say okay I'm getting
discriminated against for jobs that I'm
overly qualified for
um and that's where we see all these men
staying home or they go to work and they
realize that they're going to get a
bunch of sexual harassment complaints or
the women telling them how to talk or
whining whatever it is so they don't
like that or they go do a hard job and
honestly I think they're underpaid for
it so what do we see throughout this
whole system right of making money and
being efficient and providing value to a
society we see that the men are actively
discriminated against and the women are
given special treatment and what still
happens the men still make more so what
conclusion does that lead me to I think
the women are dumber than the men
because I think your emotions just get
in the way we're too emotional we see a
problem we get emotional about it where
the men can just think I don't make the
rules I I just I just look at the
marketplace guys so then I started to
think okay if women have these great
decision-making abilities like we so
claimed we're so mature and we're just
so good at stuff and women power women
power you would think right we would
have a female billionaire by now we
would have the equivalent of a female
Elon Musk Bill Gates but it's been a
hundred years with all this Freedom
where is she um the only thing we can
produce is Kim Kardashian so then I
started thinking about mate selection
like that's the most important thing
that we have to bring societies children
and do we do women in general select men
very well is that what we're known for
no we start to pick drug dealers
criminals and players right so so let me
get this straight all right so in a
system that primarily props us up we're
still not more efficient and in terms of
mate selection we picked terrible so
then I started to think okay okay
um is there anything women are better at
and guys I have been thinking for months
for months now I think they faked the IQ
test because I've interviewed hundreds
of men and hundreds of women and I
really think they're faking the IQ test
to make women think you know they
couldn't convince the general population
that women are on the extremes of the IQ
test because let's be honest then we'd
have some billionaires but you know
they're like okay women the average
woman is smarter than the average man
and they just they tried to convince us
this and I'm like um I don't believe
um so then I thought are We Are we more
nurturing I don't know if I spelled that
right I'm a woman okay
um Are we more nurturing and I found out
that the most likely person to kill the
child and the elderly is a woman if
someone kills their own kid 90 chance
it's the woman because again we process
things with our emotions first so if we
get angry we get upset that's that's all
we can think about it like clouds are
judgment and most women can probably
think of a time where they got super
angry or upset and did something that
they're not proud of not to say that men
don't get angry too but men have to
weigh the costs a lot more than women
because they know they might end up
killed we're women we just have no
consequence really and that's why you
see all of these women getting away with
killing babies in society I keep I keep
seeing this trend of them barely going
to jail so then I thought okay so let me
get this straight we we're dominating
the school system making less money even
though we have all these special
privileges so we're not smarter than men
then I started to think okay
um we're not more nurturing than men and
then I thought okay well maybe we're
better Cooks right aren't we supposed to
be these like amazing Cooks all the top
Michelin chefs so um guys please I know
it's I I sometimes I click bait a little
bit it's not all women are dumb but I
just think as a group women are dumber
than men and I think it's okay and I
don't think it has to be this big deal
that you guys all whine and cry about
and which goes back to the real problem
which is female narcissism I think we
all think we're more special than we are
we're more important than we are and
number one smarter than we are nothing
like a woman that thinks she's so smart
well let me know what you guys think in
the comments maybe Pearl's just going
crazy again Mad you know insane
um and let me know what you want me to
cover next time subscribe to the channel
and I'll talk to you next time